coming from being an old-school wii what
is your opinion
of like the modern anime scene in modern
anime cultures oh man
okay um so i think so
this is the interesting thing is when i
moved here right you'd think like oh
now i have unlimited access to all this
stuff i'm gonna i can just do it now
i actually didn't actually end up
quitting
you know what you know what i quit on
well the last thing i actually sat down
and watched like i'm gonna sit down and
watch this was the k
on movie wow it's such a [ __ ]
throwback oh my god
[ __ ] why i don't know but just i watched
that and i'm like
i would quit anime watching okay okay
question did you like the kale movie
no i didn't did you like keon though i
like chaos
okay okay okay something nice about the
thought of someone in the cinema
watching k
on and then thinking i'm done with anime
now
for me i don't know if it was maybe it's
just like that's enough or
yeah maybe it was because a combination
of like well now i'm in japan it's like
all this stuff that you see
doesn't feel as like unique in it yeah
well it's like it's there it's it's
it's not as romanticized anymore right i
don't know if i read it somewhere or
someone's told me this but
when you come to japan you realize that
manga artists are actually they're not
creative they're just
really good at representing real life in
a very consumable way
right that's true yeah and and that's
not a bad thing obviously that's great
like you you
you get that's really good about reading
like
the sort of like the daily life genre
like chaos like
like like yotsuba like all those sorts
of things it's
all the stuff you see in those is real
life just sort of compressed into like a
a form where you can consume it all
really quick
and i think that's that's a great thing
that makes it really enjoyable to to
read or watch or whatever
but i just sort of like yeah that'll
that'll do and
unfortunately that was also at the peak
of what is
was i guess was known as like the moi
blog yeah
yeah and it just kind of ended up i
don't know it just sort of turned me off
like yeah
i i don't know yeah as much as i as much
as i love the moe blobby or
like kind of halfway through it i was
like all right can we get something else
now i i i hated the mo
blobbier i remember like i so the reason
i haven't watched format to alchemists
was because
that was during the moe blob era and
that was when i thought i needed to save
shows in case i lost my faith in anime
because
there were there wasn't enough shows
coming out per season to like keep my
interests
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then the east
coast era started i'm like
okay boys i'm good the what the isakaya
so now now we're
now we're in the east coast yeah okay
now i i hate that
i like that i'm sorry i like that you
hate that i'm sorry everyone i just
can't stand isikai
i don't want to i don't want to see a
bunch of normal teenagers in like some
fantasy you know like i get it it's it's
cool but it's
it's it's not it's it's not it's not
cool as someone who likes the east coast
i can definitely say
like most of it is [ __ ] trash it's
not self-aware enough it's like yeah
it's it's basically like an rpg game but
it's real it's like
all of you would get annihilated the
first time you faced an enemy
all these characters and stuff what's
the original um there's a one called
escaflonade you know that
yeah yeah yeah i guess that's like an
original sort of
that was that was an isakai before the
real the modern east
formula really started good i think
because it was like it was like you were
dragged into this world and it was all
this crazy [ __ ]
yeah whereas now it's more like yeah
this is us
yay and it's just like i don't know that
that just turned me off even more yeah
i'd say like uh gun and i covered this
when we did the we when we did an issac
animation list but escaflone
and uh now and they're here and now are
probably the two shows from like the 90s
that like really kind of built the
foundations
i said there's in usher as well yeah as
well and then dot hack came along yeah
kind of like put in the whole like video
game aspect yeah so
the sakai thing and then and now we're
here and it's just
because i i feel like east kai back then
it was all about you get transported to
this world but it was always about
finding your way back home yeah because
it was always like it was always a
desolate kind of
rough world to be in but now it's all
about man i like this place
i want to get hit by a truck so i get i
get transported to another world and
there's so many [ __ ] shows where it's
a teenage boy
who's a [ __ ] in cell then he turns up
and eight girls want to [ __ ] him
and then it's never mentioned that he
came from another world ever again
unless it's kind of convenient for why
other people want to [ __ ] him yeah
i'm so bored of this [ __ ] man can i get
something else
please yeah he needs to say it i'm kind
of bored with
each kind the other one too i don't know
this is kind of controversial or not but
the the genre of where okay how do i
explain this
where you have it's like a harem anime
but
the main character is not male they're a
female
they're female but it's like they're
basically a male but
for the for the convenience of the story
they're female like what's the what's
the dragon one
uh dragon one the the uh with um
with uh are you talking about are we
talking about stuff like oran high
school no no
no no the one with what's that character
and the other and the other one
oh yeah like the main character is a
female but it's
it's actually male if you think about it
like it's like it's like the position of
a male right is that right yeah it's
like no no no it's
there's other ones like that too where
it's kind of like yeah the main
character is female but it's
it's it's it's an analog of a male but
it's female so it's okay it's just like
uh it's just even worse
i don't know yeah i i get i get the
genre you're talking about i'm just
trying to think of like other ones that
kind of fit into that
i can't remember the name of them but
it's this other ones too where it's kind
of like that it's like
it's cool so you didn't like dragon maid
no i didn't like really
it's just kind of two on the edge of
like of like
it's not it's not actually lewd guys
[Laughter]
not gonna lie if it was a toss-up
between watching anime and just
[ __ ] tearing a car to shreds on a
track yeah i do a tarot card
yeah it's probably going to be my hobby
that's very realistic like i mean
i think the only difference is uh
there's a six dollar a month
subscription and like a 30
000 problem how much is it does it cost
to drift on a yearly basis for you man
it can it can it can vary but you're
throwing another profit if i had to
throw out a budget like okay you're
gonna need this much to a year to drift
uh car fuel insurance
registration maintenance and
the occasional like you're gonna stuff
it into a wall yeah
yeah and you're gonna break a bunch of
[ __ ] ah
at minimum maybe at minimum maybe like
thirty
thousand dollars if you want to drift
maybe
maybe once a month or once every couple
of months at like one track day
i mean needless to say the kids don't
get good christmas presents
no i'm kidding would you like
you're like daddy's got you something
special she's a [ __ ] up tire
there you go
just buy them and use our tires and like
are you gonna use that
if you can't use that daddy can use that
you know some premium oil for you here
children
have you ever thought about getting an
itasha yourself yes
oh really what would you what would you
get what would you get after the zero
hesitation
of course okay i turned 40 years old
this year so i don't know
how i i really don't know see there's
two ways you can do this there's the one
way we can just be shameless and like
this is my waifu
but there's the other way like because a
lot of western people
are very like timid when it comes to the
itasca like it'll be like
dragon ball or yeah like something where
it's not like
yourself no no no no it's no no it's not
whereas here it's like some
studio leaf you know like visual novel
so i guess if i was going to do it i'd
have to go i'd have to go
hard in and go like okay yeah who is
that i just don't know i don't have any
these days i mean i thought
who's you who was the og waifu for you
like the one that you first was like yes
this is my waifu ah
a long time ago i really liked lam from
uraci
that's the og you
[Music]
you've probably seen her she's the one
with like the green hair and like the
tiger
i just got this great image of you like
like rocking up to your kids scoring
like an idol mastercard
just like picking other kids like come
on kids